you look great thank you i love the bag
what's in jason momoa's bag it's pretty
simple it's just a
lip balm something special and uh my
phone
something's good
what's the special thing just for me
well final season of c
look i think your character baba voss is
correct me if i'm wrong but a family man
the family is everything to him how much
do you relate to that and why do you
love playing that character
i mean
obviously i'm a father and a family man
and um
there was just a lot i'd have the
opportunity to play it dad in a series
before and then to have them
be babies oh there's my
head is here
wow
[Music]
so nice to see my my fellow castmates um
sorry she threw me off
um i love playing a dad on this one yeah
i do it's um i love playing uh having a
full arc it's not it's not just killed
off in the first season or
or it just doesn't end properly it's
nice that it's three seasons and it's
catered to
you know
the the final chapter you get to go
through everything and you get to see
what happens and
it was intended that way and those
battle scenes i mean right in the first
episode like oh bigger and better than
ever i watch them and i'm like ow
that's why i heard ow
i wouldn't and you look back and like i
would never do that again and then sure
enough i do it again
now you know i got asked about a couple
other projects we're excited about
you're playing the villain and fast and
furious how is that
i've never played a character that
what's the word
he's very very uh he's evil and quirky
and
androgynous and he's he's very
sadistic and fun
it's very bizarre that's fun though it's
so fun
and i haven't played a villain in a very
long time so they've welcomed you into
that family very much yeah very much all
the hype all the buzz all the talk
aquaman two what can we expect have you
talked to amber how are things it's just
laughs i i i've never uh
me and patrick
it's it's a it's a bit of a brother's
journey and so it's a lot of funny stuff
and there's a lot of stuff that's just
what's going on in our environment
talking about climate change and just
hitting on certain things that i wanted
to hit on and um
yeah it's just a lot of laughs
and also a lot of pain so just wonderful
action to the next level okay and
game of thrones just premiered the
prequel i'm excited to see i haven't
seen it yet yeah i know but i haven't
seen it yet i'm dying to see yeah it's
wonderful
huge numbers jon snow's getting a
prequel where is call drogo's break
really are they really i'm too old now
they got to hire someone else now i
disagree yeah i'm old
well you look great by the way glad to
see you're okay after the motorcycle
thing like are you good yeah yeah the
port yeah the poor man uh it was
actually a motorcycle that hit my car
kind of came on the other side so i'm
happy he's good and alive and well and
car's good do you have a date tonight
are you here solo i'm here with my
family
did you see him there's my cousin right
here
yeah how is he as a cousin
he's a great cousin he's the best cousin
ever
yep so i'm here with my whole family
so it's wonderful
[Music]